i have a habit
um that i'd like to share though i think
is a good one
um
when a friend has a set and this this
actually this is gonna be you know this
is a relatively recent development
because i've become a public figure and
so i i know other public figures but
whenever anyone's going through
something shitty
and i find out about it i just send them
a private message being like hey you
know keep your head up it's going to be
fine
because i just know that they they feel
like all this stuff coming at them
uh and i just want them to remember that
it's nonsense for sure you know what
that's a really good thing it's one of
the things i teach in my class at
harvard that we have a tendency to think
that that the bad feelings that we get
that are provoked by a bad event that is
permanent because that's the way our our
mind wants us you know if a tiger's
chasing you you want in that moment to
think that tiger's gonna be chasing me
forever and so you you muster all of
your energy to get away but the truth of
the matter is that your brain the bad
feelings are going to dissipate that's a
phenomenon called homeostasis you will
go back to equilibrium you just don't
know it in that moment and it's very
very important i mean sooner or later
your friend is going through a tough
time got fired business went under they
got a really horrible article about them
in the new york times whatever it
happens to be or on a smaller scale you
know that they're
something those are pretty much the
types of things i'm talking about
and and so they're going to feel better
but when you when andrew writes a text
saying it's going to be okay keep your
head up trust me this is a this is a one
week story yeah what you've done is
you've accelerated the homeostasis of
those bad feelings for that person you
can literally
help somebody's basic negative emotions
to dissipate you can you can you can you
can affect the neural circuitry of your
friend by simply sending a text saying
trust me this is a one week story
you know so i want to confess something
else this is a little bit of insight
into uh into the life of someone who's
in the public eye so occasionally i
received those messages from friends
being like hey you know it's gonna be
fine and then my reaction is actually
mixed because i'm like oh [ __ ] i guess
they like they saw that like i guess it
must have been really bad yeah exactly
like i guess they saw that freaking
thing that i was like yeah no one's
gonna see that yeah and then you get a
bunch of text you're like oh i guess
people did see that yeah yeah um so when
i send these texts it's from something
objectively like i could not have missed
yeah for sure you know it's interesting
that i i you know that actually happened
to me when i was first the ceo in
washington running this think tank at
the at the center of political
controversy and i handled something
publicly really wrong and i got just i
just got barbecued in the washington
post and you know a bunch of i just
didn't handle it very well
and uh and and i was feeling horrible
like this is gonna dog me forever yeah
catastrophized which is a real
cognitive problem that people do you
know something goes wrong like this is
gonna be horrible forever i thought this
is going to dog me for my whole career
this is it i failed it's going to be out
it's going to be written on my terms
you know human resource issues or you
know whatever it is and my neighbor
across the street was this grizzled
washington veteran i lived in bethesda
at the time and he has been hit this guy
had been through the wars a hundred
times and he said so i signed the paper
and i'm like oh you saw in the paper he
says you know
i deal with crises all the time on a
scale of zero to ten in severity this is
a
.025 wow that's so nice to hear and it
was at first i thought you know this sob
is minimizing my pain and i thought no
no actually he's he quite objectively
he's assessing the severity of this
problem and he's helped he helped me get
back on you know homeostatically getting
back to a kind of an emotional
equilibrium and so the key thing for us
all to remember is when bad things are
happening not going to last on the other
hand andrew when good things happen
they're not going to last either and one
of the things one of the parts of the
striver's curse that i talk about in
this book
is that you know one of the things that
a lot of people watching us they have
they might not be have an alcohol use
disorder or be addicted to drugs but
they're success addicts and one of the
things that success brings you
professionally and socially
is that it gives you a hit of dopamine
in your brain and you you become an
addict for that you want the success hit
again and again and again and the reason
you're never satisfied the reason that
it's so hard when you achieve something
and you're off that mark is because
you're in true deficit dopamine deficit
and that's excruciating the reason for
that that it doesn't last is the same
reason that your bad feelings don't last
because your brain has to go back to its
equilibrium it's got to go back to its
baseline and that's one of the things
that we have to remember as well you
can't
through more and more and more and more
success actually attain this you need to
find a better more sustainable curve
yeah well and furthermore you need to
manage not just your halves you need to
manage your wants yeah you need to want
one of the one of the great sources of
consoles would you rather be special or
happy that's one of the questions i ask
in the book and you know as i'm
interviewing this lady for the book and
she was a
wall street titan
and she knows how it is i'm just kidding
i'll take it to my grave i mean i don't
divulge any identities in this book
because some of the stuff is so
sensitive but you know this this woman
who
has had an incredible career in wall
street but she's noticing that she's
sort of starting to miss a beat and
there are a lot of things in her life
that she doesn't like and i said well
step back you know work on your marriage
and your relationship with your adult
kids and and stop drinking and get into
the gym and and don't worry about work
so much you know you've got all the
money you could ever need why do you
keep doing this and she said
you know
i think i'd prefer to be special than
happy
and i thought to myself that's pretty
common that's the success addict's
anthem
they would prefer to be special than
happy because special gives you the hit
gives you the hit you know perfectly
there's no heroin addict on the planet
that thinks they're finally gonna have
had enough heroin
there's no alcoholic who thinks so i'm
just gonna have three more bottles and
i'm gonna i'm not gonna i'm gonna stop
spontaneously because i'm not gonna need
it anymore they just prefer to be high
than happy and this is what we do a lot
you can't get to your second curve
unless you unless you get off that that
wheel that hamster wheel of hit hit hit
success success having better wants you
know one rule of thumb i'm taking from
this conversation
i think people should take to heart
what's that visit
one friend per year for their birthday
yeah
oh yeah no no it's it's an astonishing
thing you you're never sorry you did
that
you you think uh can i afford to do it
at the time i'm so busy
i'm so busy i know but it's so true you
know it's it's you know all the things
that i remember it's incredible you know
um i remember one time i was
debating you know whether or not to go
to a friend's house
for dinner
because i'm so busy i just didn't really
have time and and i went anyway and i'm
like ah this is gonna be really late
and i don't remember anything about what
i was doing what i was so stressed out
about but that night we were
we had dinner it was in in maryland and
up on on the severn river which is it's
a beautiful place and it was it was at
dusk
and he's this friend of mine he said i
want you to see this thing and he took
me out to his garden and there was this
flower and all the flowers were closed
it was dusk all the flowers were closed
he says watch a flower i'm like what
what watch the flower i'm like okay and
ten minutes later it suddenly
opened just spontaneously
and they all opened at the same time
surely they pop open at dusk and i was
like and i remember that i'm going to
remember that it was intensely
satisfying i'm going to remember that
for the rest of my life i'm not going to
remember the work that i i for went that
evening that was the evening of the
flower and this if you go to your
friend's birthday if you if you do
something that's meaningful you know if
you look at something if you if you if
you narrow cast into the beauty that is
the little things in life
then you'll get the intense satisfaction
that you actually seek but sitting on
that treadmill
hit you're never going to get enough
dopamine that you're going to be
ultimately satisfied
one fascinating tidbit in your book was
that apparently the loneliest
professions
are doctor and lawyer yeah uh and so i i
wanted to dig into that a little bit
though i did remember because i was an
attorney in a past life for five months
and you went to law school for three
years and then you practiced as a lawyer
for five months yeah that's right my
asian parents were very pleased
they were very pleased for five months
no no they they were pretty pretty sad
but
um
are you kidding i didn't go to college
till i was 30. i had a gap decade
imagine how fun that was for my
professor parents
wow so parents take it easy you're guys
everything can turn out okay
i do remember reading at the time that
lawyers had the highest average alcohol
consumption of any profession yeah um
but this spoke to this striver's curse
you
write about um in large part because
apparently a lot of high achievers
self-medicate via alcohol they do
according to oacd as a matter of fact
alcohol use disorder is predominates
among people with high socioeconomic
status in the united states especially
among men which is not the stereotype no
no we think about people who are down
and out as getting drunk and the people
who are using alcohol to blunt anxiety
to make it possible to unwind to get the
machine off is actually more common for
for strivers than it is for people who
are not strivers now that the truth is
that addiction is a very funny thing we
tend to become addicted to the to the
thing that self-medicates us for our
particular malady and so you find for
example that that that kids adolescents
who are struggling to focus who have
maybe some attention deficit issues but
it's it's unremediated they tend they're
way more likely to get addicted to
nicotine you know they're way more
likely to start smoking at 13 or 14
because nicotine is an unbelievably
effective add or adhd drug it brings it
it draws it sucks dopamine into the
prefrontal cortex and allows you to
focus
so the same thing is true if you have a
lot of stress you have a lot of anxiety
you have a lot a lot of trouble making
the world slow down because you're such
a striver
alcohol is incredibly effective at
turning the switch on that the problem
is it's a messy drug and it's a
dangerous drug there's a lot of data
that show that you know that one of the
biggest reasons that people wind up
getting unhappier as they get older is
precisely because of alcohol use the
alcohol is not because of the happiness
problems the causality runs in the other
direction alcohol is a really dangerous
thing that we have and for everybody
watching us you know so one of the
things i talk about in this book is if
you want to grow old well you want to
get on that second curve you want to age
gracefully you look at your alcohol use
and look at your substance use but the
maybe the most dangerous substance of
all for the strivers is the success
addiction
this idea the self-objectification where
i'm an effective person i'm a i'm i'm
going to make it's it's weird and we all
fall prey to this my my father died a
long time ago i mean my father died in
2002 when he was pretty young
and i still think all the time wonder if
he'd be wondering if you'd be proud of
me i wonder if you'd be proud of this
book what if my dad read this book why
do you think this but we tend to we're
very tied to the expectations even of
long-term relatives and for strivers
where that those where that that that
level of expectation is sky high it's
very easy to turn into a workaholic it's
very easy to turn into a success addict
and that's a tyranny
[Music]
you